who says that all main characters are
heroic yet we know our heroes to often
be paragons of justice
often winning through the power of
positive feelings friendships and
determination but that's not very fun is
it
not realistic to boot what if we can
have main characters that instead follow
human nature
and channel the power of evil well it's
not as dramatic as that
but there are quite a few anime out
there where our main characters
protagonists or otherwise
aren't exactly shining examples of
people who have the moral high ground
still it gives them a required edge to
keep the story going in the not so
typical direction
plus evil is cool isn't it right okay
i've talked enough
it's time to go through the top 10 anime
with villainous main characters
[Music]
starting things off we have black lagoon
living a monotonous life rokuro must
have been waiting for some divine
intervention to help spice up his daily
trudge through the boring every day
well divine intervention did come just
not in the form that anyone would have
prayed for i mean who'd pray to have
their lives changed in the form of
capture by a mercenary group calling
themselves black lagoon
circumstances then force him to
cooperate with this squad that makes his
living by less than virtuous means it's
truly survival of the fittest as rokuro
finds himself needing to adjust to this
hellhole he finds himself in black
lagoon is a high
octane thriller that seeks to dive into
themes like morals and virtue
it's an exciting look at rokuro's
character as his worldview begins to
transform
thanks to his less than moral crew i
mean surrounded with a cast full of
jerks
psychotic and outright evil characters
who wouldn't do so
if you've seen clips of revi who's one
of the main characters you know exactly
what i'm talking about
survival of the fittest is the name of
the game in such a crap sack world after
all
in eighth place is gankutsuo i don't
know about you but i just love it when
classic
literature and anime intersect and what
better piece of classic
literature to adapt into anime than one
of the most lasting and memorable tales
of revenge
the count of monte cristo now take such
a beloved tale and add some sci-fi
elements into it and you get
gankutsuo the main character being
immoral is pretty much a given if you're
familiar with the source material i mean
it's a tale of cold-blooded revenge for
crying out loud on the other hand i'd
like to bring your attention to
gankutsuo's art style i don't think that
i ever saw
anything like this before picking this
show up it surely divided the anime
community a bit when they first saw it
but whatever your reactions to that are
please don't let it hamper your
enjoyment when watching this creative
and innovative retelling of one of the
most beloved literary classics out there
ever heard of that grandpa who gets
caught in an explosion and comes out of
it a hero
well here it is inuyashiki feels the
full wrath of an explosion and comes out
of it reformed as
a cyborg while he decides to use his
powers for good
he also catches wind of another person
who's gone through what he has
the villainous shishigami now i'd say
that inuyashiki is an interesting case
for this list because honestly in most
regards our old man protagonist
is heroic unlike most of the immoral
protagonist or protagonist
allies that get featured in the shows
i've been talking about hinuyashiki
himself is
generally a good guy what i want to
focus on here is shishigami shishigami
is the villain but he's the main
character and a lot of the story is told
from his perspective
this opens up some angles to which the
story can be told and i really like how
it was done
in inuyashiki it gives you a certain
perspective that you don't expect from
what seemed to be a superhero show
inuyashiki is not a long anime so i
think that you can give it a shot if
you're in for some no-holds-barred
action featuring discussions on two
characters seated on
very opposite ends of the moral spectrum
all hail the almighty irons in our
number six show
overlord have you heard of the exploits
of the amazing ein summer once a
powerful wizard and a master of his own
guild in the vr game idracil mamonga
decides to
enjoy his last hours in the online world
just as it crumbles
only it doesn't and he gets stuck in the
body of his skeleton lich avatar
left in a world after the end he now
finds himself the master of a completely
different world
one where non-player characters seem to
have awakened to personalities of their
own now christen the overlord of this
new world momonga eventually eins olgon
begins his conquest
at his beck and call our loyal servants
of the tomb of monsters that will help
him find the answers to this predicament
that he finds himself in
overpowered protagonist anime done right
overlord sure has garnered its fair
share of polarizing opinions from its
execution
its world and its characters but being
someone who enjoyed irregular at magic
high school and the currently airing
misfit
of demon king academy i just can't help
but be a sucker for overpowered
protagonists that give
no damn about morals i do think a nice
aspect to overlord is just seeing how
the humanity in iron slowly erodes as he
continues his journey
i do also think that the other
characters deserve more shine but
reveling at the awesomeness of the
protagonist kept me in the ride with
that you more or less have an idea of
what to expect in overlord so go ahead
and see for yourself if it's to your
liking
remember that anime starring terrorist
protagonists well it's here at number
five
terror in residence terror in resonance
finds tokyo in the midst of a chain of
terrorist attacks by our protagonist duo
dubbing themselves sphinx they continue
the attacks leaving behind riddles as
their way of looking for challenging
opponents
the efforts do pay off attracting a
particular individual
kenjiro shibazaki now the battle is on
between the terrorists and the genius
set to end the duo's reign of terror the
themes of terror in resonance might be a
little bit unsettling for others but i
think that having such
extremists as protagonists opens up a
rarely explored angle in anime
terror in resonance is rich in themes
that deal with politics
morals and the like it's also rife with
tragedy and mysteries surrounding the
main duo and how we reach this
particular point
if you're up for a show that helps
reshape your understanding of the world
terror in resonance is here
fourth on the list is yujo senki
localized as
saga of tanya the evil doesn't the
pretty ominous title already sound you
off
well you're in for a hell of a ride what
happens when a remorseless hr manager
gets issacied and dropped into the
heartless midst of a war-torn land
well take her immoral skills and vicious
streak in the real world and translate
it into war of course
such is the story of tanya a protagonist
in yu josenki
tanya's every bit cold-hearted immoral
calculating and utterly ruthless
it doesn't mean that the show can't be a
fun ride especially seeing all the crazy
[ __ ] she pulls
turns out that the merciless world of
warfare is just the perfect place for a
hr manager to run wild
this crazy setup comes back with some of
the best background art and soundtrack
from recent anime that i can recall
and i can see why the show became such a
big hit if you enjoy anime with a unique
plot
are a sucker for wartime settings in
strategic plots or simply want to root
for intelligent and calculating main
characters
yujosenki could be the show just for you
91 days brings us to the prohibition era
quite the stark contrast to the
pseudo-world war world of yujo senki
here we get acquainted with angelo
lagoosa who has his own quest for
revenge against the vanities
i think it's a no-brainer as to why the
title makes it onto this list
you've got to toss aside some morals to
pursue such a quest after all the
opening scene alone establishes what
kind of protagonist we have and i think
that makes him all the more of an
interesting character to follow
personally i think that 91 days is a
show that was mostly carried by how
charismatic the main character is
and how interesting the writing of him
is the show itself is more of a slow
paced show that builds up
excellently to its climactic act the
slow burn star might not be for everyone
but those who follow through will find
themselves audience to one of the best
revenge dramas that anime can offer
it's got suspense it's got a lot of
intrigue and it has some of the most
engaging characters
found in the genre
[Music]
i was really really torn with who to
give the first place spot to
but narrowly missing out the top spot by
an inch is code geass
where can we get started with code geass
give the most magnificent
megalomaniacal genius in the world with
the power to control minds
and witness the fireworks of political
upheaval
oh and throw in some cool robots there
and some of the greatest art and
animation the late 2000s has seen
and you've got what could be the 2000s
anime of the decade
chess master just doesn't do enough
justice to describe the cerebral
abilities of the characters in this show
and it was such a joy watching the
battle of wits week after week with the
rest of the anime community back then
lelouch also isn't bound by a lot of the
morals that hold back a lot of anime
heroes so we can see the depths and full
capacity of the human mind through him
it's really telling to see how much of
an impact code geass has made
decades after its cathartic conclusion
you still see a huge fan base and a lot
of additional material heck you still
see a lot of collabs with random mobile
games out there
i do think that the only thing it lacked
is a little bit more mainstream
penetration that the number one placer
on this list had
at least locally i'd argue that in terms
of actual show quality though
code geass might as well be the number
one show on our list
so any guesses as to what comes next
on the top of the list is a suspiciously
similar show
both in terms of scope popularity and
the sheer magnificence of its
protagonist
it's death note who hasn't heard of
death note
i think it's even more of the
quintessential villain protagonist show
even more than code geass as i think
lelouch is overall just a more
sympathetic character than light yagami
for those who don't know death notes
basically what happens when you give an
arrogant hero with a god complex the
complete power to enact justice
using the titular death note light
begins his crusade to rid the world of
crime by wiping out criminals one at a
time with his handy power
as we all know absolute power corrupts
absolutely and we eventually get to some
of the best games of cat and mouse
between him and super detective
l i think it's a no-brainer that death
note gets to the top of our list
seriously what other series on this list
had as much of a lasting
impact as death note i think only code
geass which missed out on the top spot
by a hare's length can compare but given
how much of a good social commentary on
justice and morality death note was and
still is
its legacy doesn't surprise me one bit
so how's that for a lineup of shows with
immoral main
characters do these shows prove or
disprove the point that edgy is cool
tell me your opinions on the mentioned
shows that you've watched and i'm sure
that we'll have a good time talking
about your not so typical main
characters
as of now i'll take my leave with 10
shows that will help you ponder on your
world views and morals
that's plenty of time to keep you busy
until the next video
[Music]
you